yo hoy he venido a hablar
de los animales que están más explotados
y más infravalorados de nuestro planeta
estos animales de los que hoy yo quiero
hablar son criaturas inteligentes
sociales sensibles y tienen las
increíbles capacidades por ejemplo de
usar herramientas colaboran entre ellos
y tienen memoria y algunos incluso son
capaces de reconocerse en un espejo
imagino que con esta descripción que os
estoy dando la mayoría pensaréis bueno
pues que hoy he venido a hablar de los
grandes simios de los elefantes de los
delfines pues no
hoy he venido a hablar de los peces y de
hecho yo hace poco tiempo que trabajo
sobre peces durante desde hace poco y
durante 10 años yo me dedicaba a la
investigación científica en el campo de
la microbiología marina porque a mí
siempre me ha fascinado la inmensidad de
los océanos y los hilos y sus
desconocidos habitantes no sé si lo
sabéis pero los océanos son el
ecosistema más grande de la tierra
ocupan el 70% de la capa terrestre y
como dato curioso os diré que el 50 por
ciento del oxígeno que respiramos
proviene de los océanos concretamente de
los microorganismos que hacen la
fotosíntesis y aquí os he puesto un par
de fotos para que os hagáis una idea de
cómo son pero a pesar de la importancia
de los océanos conocemos aún muy poco de
cómo funcionan y de sus desconocidos
habitantes para que os hagáis una idea
se dice que conocemos mejor la
superficie de la luna que el fondo de
nuestros océanos y por eso yo me dediqué
durante tanto tiempo al estudio de los
microorganismos del mar
pero desde hace poco desde hace poco
perdón
me dedico junto a varios compañeros de
la ong compassion in world farming que
es una ong que se dedica a la protección
de los animales y que en español quiere
decir compasión en el mundo de la
ganadería industrial nos dedicamos al
estudio y a la protección de los otros
grandes desconocidos organismos
acuáticos que son los peces yo decidí
hacer este cambio en mi carrera
profesional y a la vez en mi vida porque
yo siempre he sido una gran apasionada y
una gran admiradora de los animales y
del mundo animal y me preocupaba pero
sobre todo me indignaba muchísimo como
tratamos en díaz mejor dicho como
maltratamos hoy en día a los animales
los peces son los animales que menos
valoramos del planeta
y además siempre ha generado bueno no
han generado mucho interés ni mucha
curiosidad por el público en general
pero yo hoy os quiero mostrar que son
animales y igual de curiosos de
interesantes y de inteligentes como el
resto y espero con ello que puede
despertar nuestra admiración vuestra
curiosidad pero sobre todo vuestro
respeto hacia ellos porque yo creo que
se merece se merecen la misma
consideración y la misma protección por
parte de nosotros
los peces son seres sintientes y
perciben su alrededor se adaptan a su
entorno y tienen un amplio mundo
sensorial yo no sé si os la habéis
planteado nunca pero los peces ven
debajo del agua y ven tan nítidamente
como nosotros vemos en el aire y ven en
color incluso ven más colores que
nosotros
los peces también oyen debajo del agua
aunque no tengan orejas pero si no
tienen orejas es porque no las necesitan
porque el sonido se transmite mucho
mejor en el agua que en el aire
los peces también tienen el sentido del
gusto y lo sabemos porque tienen papilas
gustativas como nosotros en la lengua
pero también las tienen en el labio y en
el hocico
y los peces también tienen sentido del
olfato un fino sentido del olfato que es
muy útil para los peces que son
migratorios para orientarse
además de estos sentidos los peces
también tienen otros sentidos que
nosotros no poseemos por ejemplo los
tiburones las mantas y las rayas tienen
el sentido de la electro recepción es
decir que pueden generar y percibir la
electricidad
y otros peces tienen sensores que les
permiten detectar los cambios de presión
del agua y los cambios de vibración del
agua eso les permite también orientarse
y evitar colisiones y también pueden
detectar gràcia estos sensores los peces
que nadan a su alrededor pero no solo
detectan el pez sino también el tamaño y
a la velocidad que va
y curiosamente otros peces también
tienen unas células que les sirven como
brújulas estas células detectan los
campos magnéticos de la tierra y
entonces permite a los peces migratorios
orientarse
pero aparte de todo este gran mundo
sensorial que tienen los peces los peces
también tienen comportamientos muy
inteligentes y muy complejos sabemos que
los peces muchos de ellos son sociales
viven en grupos y no son aleatorios
tienen jerarquías y se reconocen entre
ellos y como decía no son grupos
aleatorios se coordinan para nadar
juntos los peces también juegan los
peces hacen rituales de apareamiento
entre machos y hembras y los peces
tienen buena memoria la típica frase que
decimos para referirnos a alguien que
tiene mala memoria decimos tienes
memoria de pez bueno pues eso es un mito
y es complemente completamente erróneo
los peces tienen muy buena memoria
de hecho los peces son capaces de
aprender como este pez arquero que vemos
aquí que ha sido entrenado para
distinguir entre diferentes caras
humanas y lo adiestran igual que
adiestra haríamos nosotros a nuestro
perro le dan premios de comida cuando
acierta la cara que tiene que reconocer
recibe un premio de comida
los peces también cuidan de sus crías
aquí vemos una especie que es un cíclico
que introducirá todas sus crías en el
interior de su boca para protegerlas de
un posible depredador esta madre es
capaz de estar dos meses sin comer para
proteger a sus crías
y los peces usan herramientas aquí vemos
otra especie de cíclidos que está
cogiendo una concha del par para
intentar abrirla lo que usará es el
borde de una piedra que la golpeara para
poder abrir la concha y comer su
interior el comportamiento de utilizar
herramientas hasta hace poco se creía
que era exclusivo de humanos porque es
un comportamiento muy complejo pero
recientemente hemos visto que muchos
grupos animales lo pueden realizar y
entre ellos los peces
este pez sabe perfectamente lo que está
haciendo no es un comportamiento
aleatorio
y sabe por qué lo está haciendo y con
qué finalidad lo hace de hecho repetirá
el comportamiento hasta que sea capaz de
abrir la concha
y los peces también colaboran entre
ellos como este mero y esta morena que
colaboran para cazar el mero ha
detectado presas dentro de la roca los
agujeros de la roca y avisa a la morena
que gracias a su forma alargada podrá
introducirse dentro de los huecos y
hacer salir las presas y así los dos
serán capaces bueno intentarán cazar las
presas este comportamiento de colaborar
entre especies es muy raro en el mundo
animal la capacidad de comunicarse entre
dos especies diferentes pero en cambio
sí que sucede en los peces
y el problema de los peces es que no los
vemos ni los imaginamos como yo los
estoy describiendo hoy si yo por ejemplo
los nombro la palabra atún seguramente a
la mayoría se os vendrá a la cabeza la
lata de atún pero a pocas personas se
les viene a la cabeza el animal que es
el atún y el animal el atún es un animal
que puede llegar a medir tres metros
pesar 700 kilos y es uno de los animales
acuáticos más rápidos que existen puede
llegar a alcanzar los 80 kilómetros hora
incluso pueden sumergirse a 1000 metros
de profundidad el atún es uno de los
grandes depredadores de nuestros océanos
en cambio cuando pensamos en el atún
pensamos en la latita de atún
y lo mismo sucede si yo por ejemplo os
digo la palabra salmón a la mayoría se
os viene a la cabeza el filete de salmón
el sushi de salmón pero pocos pensamos
en los animales que son los salmones y
el salmón es un animal muy interesante y
muy curioso son animales migratorios que
llegan a nadar miles de kilómetros a lo
largo de su vida para retornar al río
donde donde nacieron y desovar es decir
poner los huevos y si pueden hacer eso
es gracias a su fino olfato que puede
que les permite reconocer el camino a
casa
la gran pregunta la he querido dejar
para el final y para mí la pregunta más
importante y que quiero que reflexionéis
sobre ella hoy es
son capaces los peces de sentir dolor
y la respuesta es si los peces son
capaces de sentir dolor
de hecho los peces tienen los mismos
sensores del dolor que tenemos nosotros
y se ha comprobado científicamente que
reaccionan al dolor como reaccionamos
nosotros y que incluso muestran alivio
si les suministramos por ejemplo morfina
por lo tanto cuando pescamos y
utilizamos ganchos para pescar este pez
está sintiendo dolor es posible que
nosotros no percibamos ese dolor porque
el pez no lo expresa igual que otro tipo
de otros animales o el pez no puede
chillar pero que nosotros no podamos
identificar ese dolor no significa que
no exista
además los peces a parte de sentir dolor
los peces se estresan cuando por ejemplo
los sacamos del agua o los manipulamos
muchas de las prácticas habituales de
las piscifactorías incluyen
procedimientos que estresan muchísimo a
los animales en las granjas de peces las
densidades suelen ser muy altas y esto
estresa los animales porque son
incapaces de reproducir su
comportamiento natural
además en las granjas de peces
manipulamos a los animales por ejemplo
para la extracción de huevos y a la hora
del sacrificio capturamos a los animales
con estas redes los sacamos fuera del
agua y el método más habitual de
sacrificio de los peces es introducirlos
en estos tanques con agua y hielo
directamente sin anestesia
la mayoría de estos animales morirán por
asfixia y esto será una muerte lenta y
dolorosa
los peces fuera del agua sienten lo
mismo que nosotros dentro del agua se
asfixian se ahogan pero después los
peces pueden llegar a tardar en asfixiar
sé mucho más tiempo que nosotros pueden
ser minutos pero incluso horas aquí
vemos como los peces si llegan a ser
empaquetados que siguen vivos y esto
este vídeo que os puedo mostrar es
gracias a una de las investigaciones que
hicimos desde de nuestra ong este pez
lleva a que una hora y media y sigue
vivo empaquetado y vivo
yo creo que esto es una muerte cruel y
que no deberíamos permitir que esto
sucediera creo también que los peces se
merecen una muerte digna y con una
muerte digna me refiero a una muerte sin
dolor sin estrés y sin sufrimiento
esto es lo que sucede en algunas de las
granjas de peces pero si hablamos de los
barcos industriales de pesca la
situación no es mucho mejor
los barcos de pesca están dotados de
estas redes gigantes que en un solo día
con una sola red y un solo barco llegan
a pescar millones de animales
después del estrés de ser capturados en
el agua y ser subidos a bordo la mayoría
de estos animales siguen vivos estos
animales morirán por asfixiar a algunos
por aplastamiento a otros se les
revientan los órganos por los cambios de
presión del agua al subirlos a bordo
cuando los subimos a bordo siguen vivos
muchos de ellos y seguimos trabajando y
manipulando las redes cuando los
animales siguen vivo aquí vemos tres
personas que están andando encima de la
red cuando el animal sigue vivo si esta
red estuviera llena de cachorritos o
gatitos estaríamos escandalizados pero
como son peces no nos da igual nos
parece de lo más normal
el número de peces que matamos
anualmente es desorbitado para que os
hagáis una idea matamos 4.000 millones
de mamíferos para el consumo humano
anualmente
si hablamos de aves sacrificamos 70 mil
millones y aquí incluyo pollos patos y
pavos pero si hablamos de peces tengo
que cambiar la escala porque el número
es muchísimo mayor estamos hablando de
30 mil billones de animales que
sacrificamos anualmente yo no sé
vosotros pero para mí hacerme una idea
de que representa este número es casi
imposible entonces os voy a hacer una
comparación este número equivale a más
de 140 veces la población mundial es
decir que al año matamos en números de
peces más de 140 veces la población
mundial esto es una masacre
yo espero que con la charla que os he
hecho hoy haberos convencido de que los
peces son seres sintientes y que ahora
los veáis como los animales inteligentes
complejos
interesantes que son inteligentes y con
ello me gustaría convenceros de que
merecen el mismo respeto y la misma
consideración que el resto y cuando
hablo también de protegerlos no me
refiero únicamente de protegerlos a
nivel poblacional es decir de que nos
preocupemos de que el día de mañana
sigamos teniendo poblaciones de peces
para seguir pescando y para seguir
consumiendo sino que a mí me gustaría
que nos preocupáramos de los peces
también a nivel individual porque yo
creo que cada vida cuenta y que nos
tendríamos que preocupar de su bienestar
y de su sufrimiento y creo que ellos
merecen una vida y una muerte digna por
lo tanto hoy os invito a redescubrir los
peces
[Aplausos]